[Music]
the first thing you need to analyzes is
your company ready for change is your
company willing to look at new ways of
doing things this program
transformational leadership was designed
specifically for us to think about how
do we pivot the organization how do we
shift the way that we think as an
organization so that we can create an
organization that is more poised to
positively disrupt itself in the
landscape of disruption when a company
or an organization comes to campus to
work with us we've designed the content
to meet their needs in a very human
centered way so we are trying to drive
innovation we're trying to focus on the
future trends and the whole program is
customized in a way that works for us
the faculty director works very very
closely with the client to determine
what the content is going to be in the
program who's going to teach in the
program and what other kinds of added
benefits there might be they want to
really make sure what we're trying to
achieve and then find the right faculty
to fill those spots for us the
introduction to the d.school
they've got this wonderful way of
bringing it all together getting you to
be able to prototype being able to learn
the principles of Silicon Valley about
failing fast and then amplifying what
really works the amount of information
that faculty can condense in an 80
minute session and the relevancy to what
we do day to day is essential and it
happens every time they are not
theoretical and just let's talk about
what's in the book but they make it
practical and make it actionable in most
of our programs there's a blend of
different kinds of learning so we may
have some case studies we may have
simulations we may have experiential
activities and also a set of online
assets that can be used in a blended
program or can be used in a fully online
program for companies we have 12
different organizations within our
company coming to this program making
those networks and connections we have
now developed a common language across
the organization I know it might sound
like a cliche but we don't think that
you can afford not to do to Stanford
customized program this program is
helping us transform our company the
where we want to be at a faster pace but
I love about Stanford and the thing that
was so killing to us about Stanford is
you know you've got a faculty and staff
who is focused on actually making a
difference in the world
[Music]
you
[Music]